thank you millionaire theme our folks
these are real millionaires Jeff isn't
Fort Walton Beach Jeff what's your net
worth sir hi Dave
my net worth is was about three million
dollars now about three million good for
you what's it invested in mutual funds
mostly but real estate is what we
probably have about two thirds and
mutual funds and another third in real
estate we own four homes three three of
them are rentals mm-hmm how much did you
inherit to get started another time my
wife and I started out industry
literally industry in a vehicle and a
storage area where our belongings were
you were having a sword you were
homeless
oh my god yeah that was about 30 or 33
years ago and never borrow design the
struggle from the street got a piece of
property and for 750 dollars and move
the junk trailer on and we lived in
there no electricity no water
unbelievable story yeah I know but it's
true Wow and built up from there
saved went to college both of us cash
for our college education and how old
were you when you were on the street 25
I was 25 my lap is 28 and actually I'm
also here like where like you're like 60
now I'm 58 and my wife I will be 58 next
month and my wife will be 60 in October
so yeah it's going back oh you know a
lot of years
well you never forget those years you
know I mean I want hear you that leaves
a mark what you do for a living all
these years
well since then my wife and I we
proposed for a living did everything for
a living I did everything from custom
rototilling to gardening my wife worked
in a grocery store but while we were
going through school we scraped every
penny went to college education and then
we both graduated with our ends so it
became registered nurses okay and and
then we were living in a high life here
after that I hear yes so it 33 years
you've been working what was your
average income during that 33 years
the typical year income typical year my
wife and I would probably woman got our
RN to a probably making 25,000
so looking at 50,000 and but we we never
forget where we came from and I tell you
Dave
we still live very very frugally I'm I'm
guessing because we have no debt never
had any debt never will have any debt
you know we listen we live on twelve to
twelve fourteen thousand about a year so
that's I was gonna ask you how you turn
this kind of income into three million
dollars it's basically I've lived on
nothing for a very very long time but
not nothing compared to homeless nothing
compared to other people exactly we
think we live a really great lifestyle
even though my vehicle is twenty years
old how many new cars have you ever
bought one this year bought my wife a
car a car finally died actually she got
me killed car accident it wasn't beer
too many this year at even dent there
was a great discussion that she ended up
with a Hyundai all right all right
that's good she's got a brain Hyundai
huh three million dollars dollars to be
honest with yes we look at it as
security we don't have any children
we're both gonna live in a really long
time and you know there's not going to
be anybody to take care of us and I
don't I don't put in any working Uncle
Sam taking care of us so what do you
tell people when they say you can't make
it in America today well that's
absolutely not true I mean we're my wife
and I are who's that you know you just
got to have a little determination you
know put off the immediate satisfaction
for you know for future you know
security and it's it's difficult I'm not
saying it was ever easy it sounds like
the best thing that ever happened to you
is you started homeless did you have so
hard to never be back that's exactly
right now I never will be back yeah no
you won't be you've done very very well
congratulations Jeff you're a great
American story this is what it's about
I love it yeah thank you for sharing
that with us sir we're honored to have
you today thank you Wow three million
dollar net worth average income a fifty
thousand fifty eight years old one new
car in his life
mutual funds in real estate average
millionaire the CEO will talk to a few
more this is the Dave Ramsey show